hello and welcome to this video playing
gender man from the Netherlands whoa
god- score how is that possible and now
k of course I can ever my task or but
still it's minus 1 so have to do
something here yeah I went one year for
for a change of pace yeah get the maroc
see why not okay this is not a man Roxy
bite out of them accelerate its dragon
but still this kind of formation I'm
kind of happy about that I think I have
some reasonable body of experience on
this position but ok I'm going to play a
little bit differently of course get
stuff lined up against the skin I'm
threatening a five now I believe now
let's see seems dangerous to me pieces
are yeah okay this is the kind of last
resort yeah you don't want that but what
can you do so I'm going to apply night
f5 and he's grabbing okay mmm knight
Knight to g5 very likely it's right when
I can take a 4 mm hmm a couple of
options 95 is also quite decent i think
i'm going for that
and I'll take with this opening up both
diagonals yeah he can do that but i
still think with the two diagonals open
I should have a very indecent position
let's see I'm glad to go with the Queen
though yeah I think I know here to
attack form yeah I want to keep that
want to keep that Bishop one is taking
an option and I want to keep the bishop
mm-hmm okay okay okay I don't think he
can't take that night I mean would be
very surprising if that works with
everything lined up against the king I
didn't calculate I have to admit him but
I would be surprised if that it works
maybe a dust but okay if I take with the
Queen s Bishop g7 probably can also take
with the bishop hmm
now gets its NT the problem okay I take
this Gucci up g7 is still a very decent
defense there I'm look at was a bit
hasty I really hated a setup I wanted to
punish it but it didn't didn't work out
that well okay let's push it 45 here
it's still not easy for him it probably
is objectively not working it off white
but playing it is a is a different
matter so green age for Scott age 6
let's line up here
yeah now look aged three years kind of i
can also sacrifice on age seven i guess
but this is strong I don't see how a
notch is six maybe I'm overlooking too
many things here really do ah and I
Jessica's not exactly difficult this is
the worst part of it okay I can still do
that for Queen age five maybe but it
wasn't necessary to go for this stuff
could have had it easier 130 not even a
checking d7 well I'm very slow here but
it's been a long day I have to have to
save it still taking a long time to see
stuff that's actually important that d7
is attacked and I think Bishop takes be
to Queen age five is just immediate
immediately over
yeah I think he's I think he's busted
probably am overlooking stuff again but
it looks pretty awful so what now h7 or
work look he is also pretty strong
time warning
hmm ice don't see a wind which is
probably maybe there is none
I don't see you in I'm not even
threatening stuff I mean it's not
completely obvious what you should do
but Jeff Jeff he can actually still safe
as safe as i can still save that check
how damn it I didn't see that his last
king of age here ah what if what a
terrible thing what Terrell check check
now I was certainly something better
yeah it's certainly too slow God not
shake me how I should and now you can
look at how how how I could have
checkmated him which was certainly
possible cannot believe this one bit
this kind of thing here now so here here
here I'm winning it which is a kind of
clear there should be a win it wasn't
working at the first place of course we
have to be perfectly honest at that
sacrifice um was not sound okay yeah now
he's screwing this stuff up here right
and I don't want you to pay Musa come on
I just I'm sorry that was the wrong
wrong game i suspicion h7 set of night
h3 and instead of Route 83 yeah I said I
didn't see 96 of course but here it's
still winning with Quincy form this is
just far too much this is winning this
is winning here d take screen age 5 and
over it just which is far too much hard
too much I'm gonna attack ruge f8 so
strange move anyway night have AIDS what
I expected but I still have to win check
so he says this should win Janet doesn't
do
dear black holes probably check check
check check and black hordes this is
this is right i mean i've got everything
lined up i just have to take in fire but
this also wins it must win it's
impossible not to I mean what kind of
attacking position is that so this is
also again winning Bishop takes Queen
cakes is easier Knight takes pawn takes
lots of winning it was you have to be
precise than the attack I did this and
now it still wins but it's difficult
it's much more difficult this seems to
win king back King King edge 8 and now
this and Queen f5 ah i mean this is this
is something that the engine is giving
and I mean it's kind of it's easy to
believe that White's attack wins but
it's not easy to play the computer gives
stuff like that there's this Bishop here
Luke g4 and then yeah weird stuff it
gives weird stuff like this there's some
some kind of positional moves and it
just gives plus 2 I mean like it's tied
down I understand that okay well now I
see okay this is a concrete idea
and wins yeah it was difficult it was
difficult I mean I was kind of losing
the threat here it's still good
compensation but it doesn't seem to be a
win oh yeah I can win again with Bishop
b5 and then it should also looked
strange but I'll this actually just went
but does this no this is not Brook
giannis check we win here I hope she ate
our book g8 oh my god dad I had many
chances to win this game yeah this is
this is kind of easy i just take it
check check check your and so on hmm
check yeah Jeff thought that I had this
check and check he has king evade simply
yeah he I'm I'm out of all the fiery we
could have taken the Queen yet check it
doesn't matter though check it's the
lost of course yeah yeah I've got three
minutes yeah I have enough time I have
enough time to figure this out I was
really bad I should just I just I should
just end the game here with this attack
the way it panned out especially here I
mean after you went through Kuwait I
mean this is probably good for black and
the refutation of my piece sacrifice I
mean white white can try stuff but it's
it's not objectively enough well after
you gave eight um gather tech is winning
look here here
yeah and this was okay I just this is
this is in fact relatively easy it's not
so easy to to do for a human as the
bishop won't be too as such as the
good-looking piece and taking only five
I mean it works for concrete reasons but
it wasn't apparent to me why Queen h5
there should be worse it just looks good
and again I have to take only five well
tough tough you can you can go wrong you
can go wrong in those kind of on wild
positions okay well thanks for watching